les deux enfants terribles sous les feux
des projecteurs le Musée du Jouet
célèbre tomtom et nana lors d'une
exposition événement cette bande
dessinée évoque un duo taquin débordant
d'imagination pour faire des bêtises
dans le restaurant de la famille du
bouchon c'est la pagaille les garnements
apportent un autre regard sur ce site
pisiaqueet orienté autour de la culture
de l'enfance c'est une partie qui a
vraiment pour but de mettre en valeur
les collections du fond permanent avec
des un petit clin d'œil en fait sur 10
objets des collections qui sont
interrogés par tomt et Nana en fait Tom
tomom et Nana nous prennent par la main
pour nous faire revisiter le musée d'une
façon originale c'est un jouet mécanique
qui représente un petit clown
dessinateur donc là tomtom et nana
s'étonnent parce que parmi les dessins
du clown on retrouve leur portrait paru
dans la revue j'aime lire entre 1977 et
2005 ces histoires intergénérationnelles
dévoilent leurs coulisse premier dessin
au crayon à papier ou après colorisation
le public peut découvrir les différents
stades des planches conçues par sa
dessinatrice Bernadette Despré là je
travaillais à à ce
moment-là avec cette taille c'était la
la le format j'aime lire alors qu'avant
après plus tard j'ai complètement
agrandi normalement tout le monde
connaît tomtom et nana il y a plus
besoin de les présenter et moi je suis
un peu impressionnée de ça grâce aux
parents qui les ont lu quand ils étaient
petits et la plupart du temps ils me
disent vous savez hein je vais vous dire
la vérité hein c'est que moi j'ai appris
à lire avec jouet des années 80 du musée
où produit dérivés de la BD cet espace
représente la chambre fictif de tomtom
et nana les jeunes visiteurs peuvent
aussi apporter à cette exposition leur
touche artistique vous avez une salle
qui est un espace de jeu avec différents
jeux Jeux De loie jeux de soude cou jeux
de dessin en fait qu' on peut notamment
avec des crayons effaçables apprendre à
dessiner les traits de tomtom et nana
sur un tableau effaçable c'est vraiment
très épatant c'est ma vie qui continue
là
encore alors formidable l'exposition Tom
tomom et Nana présente tout Bernadette
Despré au Musée du Jouet de poissis un
univers fcécieux pour petits et grands à
retrouver jusqu'au 7 janvier